this is the port city of taragona
down there is the train station that i
took to go to barcelona
we have uh the beach in front of us here
beautiful beach apparently the beach
beyond the point is even more beautiful
here is the uh
drambla nova which is one of the two
main sort of
pedestrian walking zones here
in
tarragona turn to the century buildings
there and of course one of the
attractions here is
the roman ruins and we'll just go there
taragona of course was a roman city
first arako
and this is not a
tourism video that i'm doing here i want
to though point out that when the romans
arrived here of course there were a
variety of languages spoken here
whatever the original spanish language
was they eventually converted however to
latin or a form of latin which
subsequently became not only spanish but
also of course catalan
and
yeah i don't have any immediate
signs here to show you that that in fact
this is the place where lots of
languages exist and this is sort of a
lead-in to my theme today
a new approach to language learning
based on the on the idea that if we
learn lots of languages we end up
learning them all
better
and so that's kind of the message that i
want to leave you with and maybe i
should get into the main themes of my
video which is learn languages better by
learning more of them
hi there steve kaufman here
from taragona
and i want to talk today about a
completely new theory of language
learning that suddenly come to me over
the last few days and i'll explain that
but first i'll show you a bit of
taragona so here we have
as you can see we have the ocean
and here we have
some roman ruins which we're going to be
exploring
and the whole city is beautiful quiet
friendly
uh catalan
5050 catalan and and
castellano
let's see how we're going to set this up
here all right
so here i've been doing interviews
six yesterday i had one this morning
have another one in half an hour
and i suddenly realized that while i
have done very little in spanish
my spanish is over the last say 20 years
i was here for my 50th birthday and i
had trouble communicating in spanish and
i remember that i bought a book
and it was the first book i had ever
read in spanish and i remember that
there were many words there that i
didn't know and that was one of the
motivations for getting into link
because i got tired of looking words up
making a list and never remembering
anything
so
that's
whatever it is 24 years ago
and here i am today having interviews
and my spanish is better than it was
then i understand better i'm speaking
fluently with mistakes but more fluently
so i'm thinking to myself why is that
and i'm increasingly convinced that it's
the fact that i have been learning so
many languages in the last
12 years i've learned
or worked at
11 languages
and so i am more fit my brain is more
fit for language learning so i am better
at language learning than i was
50 years ago i'm better at these
languages even languages that i haven't
worked at i am better at them and so
therefore the issue of language learning
is not a matter of learning the theory
like people here in spain they learn one
language essentially english like we do
in canada in the english school system
they learn french and you just keep on
trying to learn that language and you
feel you're not making progress and a
majority of people give up and convince
themselves they can't learn
and then we look at sweden where they
have
the
english language and other foreign
language television programs in the
original language as was the case in
croatia where english language skills
are very good
so then you say well all right then
first of all people say well in sweden
sweden is similar to english therefore
they learn but in croatia it's not
similar to english the pronunciation is
not similar to english nothing is
similar and yet there again they speak
with very little accent and they speak
very well so i believe that it's this
idea that they have the original version
of movies and television programs but
it's not just that this helps them learn
english
it's that this makes them more language
fit
it exposes them as kids initially to
different languages different sounds
different ways of saying things this
means then that when they go to learn
say english focus in on some of the
grammar acquires
words they're more capable of doing it
they notice things better they have a a
context
they're first of all they're they're
comfortable with the idea that they're
listening to things that they don't
really understand that well and they
manage to somehow gradually understand
more and more so this uncertainty which
is sort of accepting uncertainty which
is so important for language learning is
something that the kids acquire by
watching cartoons in strange languages
so the idea of exposing yourself to a
language and in my case learning a
number of languages makes me a better
language learner why is it that
polyglots can go from speaking three
languages to speaking eight languages
because with each language their brain
becomes more fit
so if i look at particularly the last
four or five languages where i've used
our mini stories
the many stories is like a
like a health club it's like a fitness
club it's where you start getting that
fitness you start in the middle of the
language you don't start with the colors
and the numbers and the names of the
members of your family and how are you
and that kind of you just start in a
simple context with lots of repetition
and that way you kind of train yourself
in the language and at some point you
graduate to netflix and all these other
good things that are available on the
internet
so the theory then of languages and
perhaps the way languages should be
taught
is to forget the idea of worrying about
accuracy you know if i was in a
bookstore here and i was looking for
material on catalan
and by the way we're going to have
catalan at link and because the many
stories have been done in catalan and
we're going to have them in hungarian
we're going to have them in thai so it's
just a matter of when we put it up
and
the
the idea you know i look at what they
have available to learn catalan it's
grammar explanations it's exercise books
and all of this stuff is frustrating not
real not meaningful low resonance and
doesn't help you learn whereas i know
that if i plunge myself into many
stories in catalan in no time i will
have a good sense of the language at
that point if i want to look at a table
of conjugations and stuff like that
it'll have meaning for me
but
so if we take an approach to language
learning is which is say in schools
expose kids to language
focus on comprehension focus on
exploration become familiar with
different sounds different ways of
saying things and at some point
the age of 12 at the age of 15 if these
kids who have been then exposed to a
variety of languages whose brains have
been expanded
who have increased their level of
language learning fitness if they want
to then focus on one language and i
notice myself now if i look at a
conjugation table in spanish where i've
had so much exposure especially recently
the conjugation table starts to make
sense but if i start with conjugation
tables and then i am tested on my
knowledge of the conjugation tables it
just builds up resistance to the
language and that's fundamentally wrong
and it's counterproductive so
we should have language teachers who are
trained in
teaching kids how to learn
where to find the sort of beginner
material that gets them going similar to
our many stories
where to find material of interest to
them
guides them where to find explanations
because if the kids doing i don't know
chinese and the teacher is not familiar
with structures in chinese but there's
so many websites that explain all of
that so that the the focus on language
instruction should be to expose us to
many languages
not worry about accuracy not worry about
how well you speak not even worry about
producing the language until you've had
enough of the language in you but don't
focus on just one language focus on a
variety of languages so here i am
once i come back from spain i'm going to
continue my
arabic persian and turkish so i'm
pushing this sort of multi-language
language learning to the extreme because
i think
we are approaching sort of the age of
the polyglot i've said this before that
the facilities available through the
internet
uh resources
language
you know explanation language
cooking material netflix all of that
stuff
makes it possible to learn not just one
but several languages we're not limited
by having a teacher with accreditation
in french
there is no limit and if we focus on
comprehension and focus on exposing
people to language and building up their
language fitness then at a time when
they're motivated then the learner to
focus in on one specific language
they will have a context that will make
it easier to understand the grammar
rules
to assimilate those to notice how some
of those structures occur in what they
listen to and read
and it'll just facilitate language
learning because what we're doing now is
not affected in canada there was a study
in new brunswick
where in the english language uh excuse
me in the french language in the english
language school system where they have
french for 30 minutes a day for 12 years
at the end of the 12 years the number of
kids who were
at an intermediate level of proficiency
in french in new brunswick after 12
years and 30 minutes a day was 0.66
percent so in other words 12 years of
instruction was a complete waste of time
far better to expose kids to languages
of interest to them
aspects of the language that might be of
interest to them
which at an early stage might just be
cartoons because they're not going to
select things of interest
and then let them become you know expand
their language minds develop their
language fitness and then later on
language learning will be much easier so
that's my new theory of language
learning and now i'm going off to
explore
life now
make my way back
to uh our little apartment here just
thought i would show you some more the
roman wall here
houses are built right into the roman
wall
here we come
to our square or again there's a portion
of the old roman wall
this is the place of the font
which excuse me place of the forum
so
[Music]
we're just off this
here we have some kind of institute
catalan
the arcologia
part of the wall here
this is our little square
and uh
we were able to rent
a small apartment for five days
uh everywhere you see this tarako which
is the old roman name for this town
and
we have breakfast here in the square
and if you'll see number 32 off in the
distance
that is
the building we're in we're on the
second floor
we were hanging our laundry out a little
earlier
and uh so just so you see plaza del
forum
this is where we are
[Music]
you